can you please not touch anything part
of the fun of working on a set is
finding what you can take home
afterwards while it's not always the
best practice the stranger things actors
have done their fair share of swiping
from the set keeping special props and
costume pieces from the show with the
hope that they won't get caught which
actors stole the most items from set
let's do some investigating i've thought
about stealing things and never have i'm
a good boy
oh my god see number one who wants to go
for a roll thanks to his sticky fingers
noah schnapp can go roller skating any
time he wants with his very own pair of
80s style stranger things roller skates
i'm so bad at this i'm like bambi on ice
you're good but he wasn't shy about
taking them the actor explained i
brought the roller skates home i had
everyone sign them and then took them
home with me okay we've gotta be honest
that's an epic set steal and if we had a
chance at getting a signed pair of
roller skates from this cast well we'd
be all over it number two
millie had a bloody good time on the set
of stranger things my blood
that i put in my nose for real though
how many times do we think she had to
perform nosebleeds on the set if blood
made her squeamish before she'd
certainly faced her fears and gotten
real comfortable with it so comfortable
that she wanted to make sure she had
some with her even when she wasn't on
set that seems to be the only logical
reason as to why millie would have
stolen a small vial of eleven's fake
blood to keep in her memento box this is
one she'll never forget that's for sure
and we hope she doesn't forget that she
stole it otherwise that discovery could
be a bit freaky i have a memory book so
i keep all my lipsticks from every award
show i went to my envelope from the mtv
awards and then the blood from stranger
things number three
keeping cozy is worth stealing for sadie
sync has been pretty good about not
taking too many things from set but she
just couldn't leave without bringing
something with her it wasn't like a
costume it was just like a warming
jacket from
wardrobe it has like it's just the
jackets she even caught noah by surprise
and while it is suspect sync has
explained that this wasn't a purposeful
swipe but not everyone seems totally
convinced again accidentally no but like
accidentally number four it would have
been pretty easy to leave the set with
these costume pieces we have no doubt
noah schnapp makes a decent paycheck
doing stranger things so we are a bit
confused that he felt compelled to steal
this particular costume piece i took a
bunch of underwear but that's really it
they must have been comfy no doubt we
wonder if anyone from set noticed he'd
become an underwear thief number five
shoplifting ain't cool millie
but does it really count if it's a fake
mall on stranger things i took she went
full tilt in the star court mall having
a full-on shopping spree on set without
any money involved of course it was
definitely a set store but i did take
um like corduroy jeans and a stripy red
and blue t-shirt and while it might have
been a fake gap store the clothes were
real and they looked good no wonder she
kept that stuff for herself
number six
it seems like millie was a bit desperate
what other explanation could there be
for her stealing such a small and random
item from the set or maybe she was just
trying to be like noah i took a lot of
socks any guesses on whether or not noah
stole more underwear or millie stole
more socks let's do it let's do it we'll
never know but we can imagine the
wardrobe department wasn't too impressed
with having to replace all those stolen
necessities
number seven
we've got our eyes on you caleb when it
came time to talk about what he swiped
from set during an interview caleb
mclachlan was pretty strategic about it
luckily he saved himself from letting
any spoilers slip but he also outed
himself pretty obviously we know he
stole something but whatever it was
continues to remain a mystery
accidentally i took uh like something
from set from season three we wonder if
he ever got caught number eight he looks
pretty suspicious
is it just us or does noah look like he
got caught in the hot seat we move on
right never took it okay so we've
established there is an it that he stole
but what could it be since sadie sync
gave the actor a look indicating it's
not something noah should probably talk
about it seems like his lips are sealed
we won't push it but we just can't help
but wonder what memento he snuck off set
with and we doubt he's talking about the
underwear in this case
number nine for real real though
i did a show called intruders um when i
was nine years old she may have been
young but even early on millie knew that
you've got to take advantage of being on
set by keeping any cool things you can i
took a lighter from the set it was a
prop being used on set but of all things
why did she need it what did she plan to
do with it this special lighter from
intruders wound up going into her
memento box with souvenirs from other
productions that lighter could always
help her find her light that's for sure
number 10 finn wolfhard might have some
answers on this one when he was filming
ghostbusters there were plenty of
opportunities to snag all the
ghost-busting materials but that wasn't
what appealed to the actor i kept some
shoes that i wore
on the new ghostbusters movie hey if the
shoes were good enough for ghost busting
then why not stick to him while he did
swipe the shoes generally wolfhard is
pretty good and hasn't actually stolen
much from set when asked if he'd taken
anything from the stranger things set he
very openly shared that he's never
stolen anything from that set in
particular for fear that the production
team would end up needing whatever he
stole at some point and then he'd be
found out that said he has confessed to
wishing he stole the ritchie glasses
from the movie it there's stuff that i
regret that i didn't keep like i wish i
kept the ritchie glasses and who knows
there is hope that maybe he'll get them
in future you never know maybe i could
get those back number 11
when you know
you know any fans of enola homes will
know that millie formed a very special
bond on set with one of her well her
dash i took dash which you will see this
set swipe definitely makes sense and she
was the title character so we guess
millie had some leeway in terms of what
she could keep from set for herself
extraordinary
while she did swipe it she had said
before that it was a gift but no one has
confirmed that fact either what we do
know is that dash isn't the only thing
millie kept from the enola home sect
number 12.
millie's got the tools and a corset i
must become something
unexpected the stranger things actress
has spent plenty of time in a harness
doing stunts for the sci-fi show but
ninola holmes she was dealing with a
very different kind of restriction and
instead of being glad about saying
farewell to a typically uncomfortable
and annoying costume piece millie wanted
to keep her corset for herself
[Music]
maybe she wanted to remind herself of
the struggle she injured while filming
or it could just be that she loved
getting her posture in check and that
corset will certainly do the trick being
so young these movies and shows are a
pretty formative part of the stranger
things actors lives so it makes sense
they'd want to keep these mementos from
their various projects whether they were
kept for practical reasons or just the
memories everyone seems pretty cool with
the practice of swiping some stuff from
set even if it does have to be kept a
secret for a while to make sure no one
gets in trouble which proper costume
piece would you want to swipe from the
stranger things set if you had the
chance
[Music]
you